gravitational waves are ripples in the
fabric of space-time predicted by
Einstein's laws of general relativity
but they're incredibly difficult to
detect to see them you need a detector
that can accurately measure distances
10,000 times smaller than a proton
that's crazy that's like trying to
measure the distance from our Sun to the
nearest star to an accuracy of the width
of a human hair but we have a technology
on earth that can do that a LIGO the
advanced laser interferometer
gravitational-wave Observatory and back
in November 2015 on a Monday morning
LIGO detected the first gravitational
wave that humans have ever directly
observed where they came from and what
this means for space science is nothing
short of mind-blowing this is the story
a long long time ago in a galaxy far far
away I'm not kidding 1.3 billion years
ago and 1.3 billion light-years away to
black holes were stuck in a perilous
orbit around one another getting closer
and closer
black holes are incredible objects the
pull of their gravity the amount they
bend space-time is so strong that no
light can escape them no one knows what
exists in the center of a black hole is
normal physics completely breaks down
what we do know is that they're
infinitely dense one of these orbiting
black holes was 29 times the mass of the
Sun and the other was 36 times the mass
of the Sun but they were only about 200
kilometers wide which is tiny in
comparison to the Sun which is over a
million kilometers wide and these black
holes were orbiting each other really
really fast about the same frequency as
the blade on a blender imagine that such
massive objects rotating so quickly
these orbiting masses created ripples in
the fabric of space-time called
gravitational waves and the closer they
orbited the bigger these waves got until
the black holes collided at half the
speed of light and when they merged they
formed a new black hole that rang kind
of like a bell throwing out colossal
amount of energy as gravitational waves
until it settled into a perfect sphere
and all of this happened in 0.2 seconds
and in the collision they turned a huge
amount of mass into gravitational wave
energy they lost a mass equal to three
times the mass of the Sun which got
turned into gravitational wave energy by
Einstein's equation e equals mc-squared
this created a huge wake of
gravitational waves that ripped out in
all directions at the speed of light and
and this is the thing that gets me over
that last fifth of a second this
collision released more than ten times
more energy than the total output of all
the stars in the entire rest of the
universe
it just completely boggles the mind
meanwhile on earth at this exact time
our planet was looking very different to
what we see now it was a barren
wasteland there was no grass or trees in
fact no plants or animals at all life at
this stage had only come as far as
microscopic multicellular creatures that
lived in the sea
and while the gravitational waves tore
through space towards us all of the
complex life on earth evolved and grew
plants and animals developed amphibians
crawled on land
there's extinctions reptiles and
dinosaurs and mammals more extinctions
primates evolved into all of human
civilization right up until Saturday the
12th of November 2015 when the
scientists at LIGO turned it on to begin
their initial tests a mere two days
later and the gravitational waves flew
past us and the first direct detection
of gravitational waves on earth was made
and that sound it's actually what these
waves sounded like even though
gravitational waves are ripples in
space-time and not ripples in the air
they vibrate at similar frequencies so
you can actually turn them into sound
waves and listen to them it might not
sound very impressive but detection of
gravitational waves means a huge amount
for science the results of this
detection have already been profound
this is the very first time that black
holes have been directly detected in
fact gravitational waves are the only
way you can directly to
consider this all of our knowledge about
the universe to this date has come to us
through telescopes that measure light
from the electromagnetic spectrum like
radio waves visible light x-rays or
through detectors that measure subatomic
particles but all of these existing
telescopes are completely blind to
gravitational waves
this means that gravitational wave
astronomy is an entirely new thing a
whole new way to observe the universe
and it has already solved some important
science questions gravitational waves
exist black holes exist and
gravitational waves travel at the speed
of light here's how the LIGO detectors
work there are two l-shaped buildings
one in Hanford Washington and another in
Livingstone Louisiana that make up LIGO
and also there's another detector called
Virgo which is in Italy near Pisa having
several detectors on earth means that
scientists can verify a signal from
space by seeing if it appears all of the
different detectives and they're far
apart because it means that they can see
roughly in what direction the wave is
coming from by triangulating the signal
even with these waves traveling at light
speed there's a delay of a few
milliseconds between each of the
detectors each of these l-shaped
buildings houses a thing called the
laser interferometer where a laser is
produced then split into two beams which
each fly down a four kilometer long arm
and then they're reflected off a 40
kilogram pure silicon test mass which is
hung from the ceiling it's hung from the
ceiling on a series of pendulums to
insulate it from the outside
disturbances like trucks moving past or
people sneezing when you're trying to
detect distances with the sensitivity
less than the nucleus of an atom getting
rid of external noise is very important
each arm bounces the laser back and
forth 400 times to make the arm
effectively 1,600 kilometres long in
each time around the lasers boost it to
make it stronger then after its journey
the light is collected and recombined in
such a way that if the arms are the same
length for light from each arm cancels
out producing no signal but if a
gravitational wave ripples past it will
stretch or contract each of the arms
making the light from each arm arrive at
the detector at slightly different times
that means that when they're recombined
they will no longer fully cancel out and
a signal will appear and this is exactly
what happened on the 14th of November
it's crazy to me to imagine that if they
had turned on this detector just two
days later then they would have
completely missed this signal that had
been traveling towards us for 1.3
billion years this makes me wonder what
other signals from deep space we've
already missed and what's still out
there screaming towards us waiting to be
discovered that we just don't know about
yet in fact at the time I made this
video Lycos detected another even
stronger black hole collision and we can
expect a lot more in the coming months
and years it's already achieved many of
its science goals but there's many more
is aiming for for example it might be
able to give us a more accurate measure
of how fast the universe is expanding
and so how much dark energy there is it
will hopefully be able to look at what
makes stars go supernova and might be
able to probe the very nature of
space-time and see if it's made of
things called cosmic strings but the
most exciting thing is that we don't
know what it will find this is one of
the best parts of science when you've
got a new tool to peer into a realm of
reality that you've never been able to
access before who knows what you'll find
maybe you'll discover things that help
explain some of the great mysteries of
the universe or maybe we'll find things
that we can't explain at all and then we
have to come up with new physics in any
case I find it super exciting and I
can't wait to see more results so they
go those are the basics of gravitational
wave astronomy hey I just wanted to say
thanks for all the comments on my last
video I didn't get to reply to them all
but I did read them all and the amount
of positive feedback was amazing and it
just makes me want to carry on and make
more and more of these videos so thanks
for that as for this video I didn't get
to cover everything I wanted to this
field of gravitational wave astronomy is
amazing in eight minutes you can only
cover so much so if you're left with any
questions please put them in the
comments and I'll try and reply to them
or I'll collect together the most
popular ones and do something later a
Q&A or something like that also I've set
up a patreon a care
so if you want to help support me make
these videos go take a look at that
otherwise thanks for watching and I'll
see you on the next video